squad today we write a new chapter in
the history of the nine-nine and that
chapter begins with the word jimmy and
ends with the word jab
chapter's only two words long no there's
a lot of words in between it's a long
chapter the point is today we compete
against one another in a series of games
and this year's winner receives
one day's paid vacation courtesy of
officer mark you said you needed that
day for a private matter you know what
you shouldn't even be here everyone say
thank you officer mark by officer mark
thank you mr mark now who's ready to
compete
count me in i could really use this day
off to spend some time with my husband
please we all have loved ones you're not
getting any sympathy just cause you're
gay rosa i don't think he was no i was
she saw right through me nevertheless
i will destroy you all copy that i love
your intensity now gina is gone so we're
out of a host me
please me it's my time to shine it's my
greatest showman moment
charles you can't you know who else i
told you can't letty lutz the bearded
lady but then mr barnum
gave her a stage give me my stage jacob
wait so you're the bearded lady
no i'm barnum you're zac efron and
everyone else is one of my freaks look i
would love to give you the hosting duty
so you can work through whatever weird
fantasy this is but we need at least six
players and the host can't play well
then i'll find someone to replace me
i promise you will have your circus mr
barnum i thought you were bart
no i'm the greatest showman
isn't that barnum gather up it's jimmy
jab time
ooh are you doing opening ceremonies
yeah and you might want to leave before
things get too crazy a little
plausible deniability actually i want to
record them maybe you can teach other
precincts how to throw their own
versions to boost morale no i'm not a
teacher i'm the class clown slash bad
boy with a heart of gold whatever
charles just start
ladies and gentlemen
the moment you've been waiting for wow
you went full showman
i present to you six freaks who through
a series of elaborate games
will be eliminated one by one until
a champion is crowned and that champion
shall
inherit my circus and get a day off i
was getting their railroad let me have
my fun yeah railroad let him have his
fun
as always we start the games by lighting
the ceremonial bagel of destiny ah it's
actually the baguette of destiny because
this year we're throwing caution to the
wind charles
flame me yeah hit me jabs give me jazz
and with that we commence my 10-minute
opening performance what
the crowd is ready the freaks are here
wow this is a really long performance
charlotte's pulled off a costume change
i wouldn't say he pulled it off he
accidentally got bottomless in front of
all of us
hmm we're all done how about we make
these games a little more exciting with
a wager ooh
interesting what'd you have in mind if
you win i'll do your paperwork for a
year
go on if i win i'd get your new car
you're joking right
why because you can't imagine someone
bitching like me driving a lame family
sedan
no because jake would never bet our car
yeah i would never do that but
also it's not lame it's the color of an
alcohol everyone's talking about it no
jake it's a super lame car but i don't
mind my ex-step-son kicked me out of the
house and i needed a place to crash with
air conditioning look the bed is not
happening sorry amy but this is between
jake and me
dude what happened to the cool guy that
liked to make fun bets with his best bud
okay hitchcock drop it jake doesn't do
that kind of thing anymore
he's an adult now hitchcock you're on he
is i am i don't know
yes yes you are damn it my pants
sorry everyone look away look away oh
damn
wow who knew he really is the greatest
showman
you